the writers on this season of America
are getting a little heavy-handed get a
little bit on the nose you see in this
season that we're all living through the
libs are no longer only implicitly
worshiping Satan they are overtly
explicitly worshiping Satan as the
singer Sam Smith showed us two nights
ago during the Grammys
you see he's there's fire there's a
bunch of transsexuals prancing around
there's there's Sam Smith has horns and
a devil costume on but that's not the
best part
you gotta wait for it okay Applause
cameras zooming out
the Grammys brought to you by Pfizer
you you can't you can't possibly make
that up there it is it's too much it's
too silly it's too absurd
it's too real so Sam Smith
gives a an overtly satanic performance
with all sorts of transsexuals and Fire
coming up first point there by the way
and I noticed this the other day even
before Sam Smith's
uh performance
isn't it odd how depictions of demons
how depictions of weird ghoulish
devilish demonic figures are always
androgynous
they're never super duper hyper
masculine Chads they're never beautiful
truly gorgeous women with classical
proportions and representations of
beauty they're always
androgynous they're always trans and the
reason for that is that the devil hates
human beings and sexual difference is
at the basically at the very core of
human nature the difference between man
and woman the complementarity of men and
women is right there at the heart of
human nature and the devil hates
humanity and so he tries to cut away at
the very core of humanity okay that's my
first observation my second observation
comes from cbs's response to this so CBS
one of the oldest major TV networks was
hosting the Grammys and CBS responded in
a tweet to Sam Smith who said this is
going to be special and CBS said dot dot
dot you can say that again we are ready
to worship
a major television network not cable not
satellite not internet major TV network
says
we are ready to worship Satan tonight on
the show
back in 1952
when I Love Lucy was on CBS and Lucy got
pregnant the network did not want her to
appear pregnant on air they thought that
was too scandalous they finally caved in
because I Love Lucy was so popular but
they said you can never use the word
pregnant this is why there's that famous
episode The Lucy pregnancy episode which
is said Lucy is unsunt
they use the French because they don't
want to use the English because CBS said
it was too scandalous to utter the word
pregnant back in 1952 in 2023 CBS News
will publicly Bellow hail Satan but in
you can't even use the word pregnant
seems like things have changed a little
bit seems like the culture has gotten a
little more vulgar a little more crass a
little bit more evil more than a little
bit more evil what did the performance
mean well here is Sam Smith's
co-performer a man by the name of Tim
Petrus who now presents himself as a
Woman by the name of Kim Petrus here is
what he says the show is all about
it was literally hot there was so much
fire
um well
um I I think a lot of um people honestly
have kind of uh labeled what I what I
stand for and what Sam stands for as uh
religiously uh not cool and I personally
grew up wondering about religion and
wanting to be a part of it but then
slowly realizing it doesn't want me to
be a part of it and so um yeah it's it's
a take on uh not being able to choose
religion and not being able to you know
live the way that people might want you
to live
um because you know as a trans person
I'm kind of already not I want it in uh
in religion so we we're doing a take on
that and it was kind of Hell keeper Kim
um but yeah it was so incredible that
Madonna introduced it because Madonna is
such a provocative and uh groundbreaking
artist
um and I think Sam and I definitely felt
very inspired by Madonna in this one
very inspired it was really hot it was
literally hot on stage it's so it yeah I
know it seemed like a devilish
performance but it literally felt like
hell yes that's how symbolism works
that's how that's how our lives work the
things that we do here in the physical
world represent things in the
metaphysical world and so when you dance
around pretending to have given yourself
over to the devil that is a symbol of
something that's going on in the
metaphysical world and and he says Petra
says
I I was always interested in religion
but religion didn't want me I'm not
surprised to hear him say that of course
he's interested in religion of course
the people who are the most Ardent
atheists are very very interested in
religion of course the people who are
the most Ardent even more than atheists
satanists or hedonists are very
interested in religion you don't spend a
lot of your time reacting against
something that you don't care about
but what he says is not true
what he says is
at the very heart of the sin that turns
us away from religion religion by the
way is is just giving to God what God is
due that's what it means it's a habit of
of justice that that renders to God what
he is owed and so when you when you
don't give God what he is owed or when
you disobey God you are behaving in an
irreligious way but what what Petra says
is I I want it to be religious but
religion didn't want me now of course
religion wants you why can't you be
religious oh because you're not willing
to give up your pride because you're not
willing to give up your own uh selfish
desires and you're not willing to to
Tamp those down and and follow God's
desires instead that's not religion's
fault that's that's your fault that's
not God's fault that's your fault
there's a scene in a play by Stephen
adley gerges who is a big lib but for a
modern playwright he's pretty good and
it's just played the last days of Judas
is scary at the final scene of the play
is Judas just sitting sitting alone just
saying you wouldn't want me you did I I
did everything for you and you didn't
want me Jesus and it's Jesus there Judas
can't see him and Jesus is saying no I
want you please just say say you're
sorry just please just say the word and
I'll give you everything please and
Judah says no you don't want me you hate
me you don't want me you don't want me
but it's it's a he's he's locked in a
prison of his own mind of his own making
as is Tim from address as is Sam Smith
I didn't I wanted to be religious but
religion doesn't want me no what you
want is to behave exactly on your terms
and force all of reality and force God
himself to to bend to your your
disordered perception of the world but
that can't happen
that can't happen and so you can't say
well I I'm a man I think that I'm a
woman and if you don't if you don't
affirm that I'm a woman then you just
don't want me in your religion no you're
saying something that isn't true and if
religion is to have any Merit at all it
has to be true and so you can't make a
demand that the truth itself
become falsehood just to accommodate
your disordered desires I mean this is
the depiction in Paradise Lost this is
how Milton depicts Satan is Satan says
well the mind is its own place and can
make a hell of heaven or Heaven a hell
and and Milton Satan says I would rather
reign in Hell than serve in heaven and
that's the very point the Petrus is
making and it sounds I I assume Petrus
and Sam Smith think this is really novel
and edgy and cool this is
this is the oldest trick in the book I
mean this is
this is what happened in the Garden of
Eden when Adam fell
and said oh no I'm going to disobey I'm
going to follow my own desires rather
than God's desires this is the whole
story but what's so
so crazy about it to me is
the difference in Sam Smith's career
right now go to hallow.com Knowles if
you are listening to this show you
probably know how important I consider
religion and our faith lives that is why
I'm super duper excited to talk to you
about hallow hallow is the number one
Christian Prayer app and the number one
Catholic app in the world I love hallow
the app has everything that I need to
maintain a daily prayer routine it's got
over 6 000 audio guided prayers
meditations and peaceful music playlists
plus daily reminders will encourage you
to keep up with the routine you know how
much I love father Mike schmitz's Bible
in a year podcast it's really the only
podcast I regularly listen to you can
listen to it on Hello
you can pray alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim
Caviezel or Jonathan Rooney who plays
Jesus in the new hit series The Chosen
just like physical exercise daily
spiritual exercise is critical to your
well-being you are supposed to be holy
and you can't be holy if you don't pray
it's especially true in a world that
that attacks faith and religion
constantly try hallow for three months
for free at hallow.com
Knowles but what's so
so crazy about it to me is
the difference in Sam Smith's career
because I really I I know it seems silly
that on this political show I'm talking
about this British singer so much but I
I like Sam Smith
I actually think Sam Smith is a pretty
good singer and you think about that the
first song probably the main song that
most people know from him Sam Smith's
crazy
listen listen to what the song is
talking about
I can't believe you let me down
the proofs in the way it hurts
I wish this would be over now
but I know that I still need to hear
I'm crazy
cause you don't think I'd know what
you've done
it's a beautiful song as far as pop
music goes I'm not the only one that's
what it's actually called and what's the
story of it the story of it is I we made
a vow we got married I really wanted to
be married to you I love you and and I'm
heartbroken that you've engaged in all
sorts of sexual deviancy and you've gone
and cheated on me
and I'm really heartbroken and it's
beautiful the melody is really quite
beautiful there and his voice is
obviously terrific
now compare that to this song that he's
sang at the Grammys what's crazy about
the song is it's about the same thing
it's about a married couple where the
man goes out and cheats on the wife
the difference is that in this new
version
Sam Smith is celebrating he's getting a
kick out of the man cheating on his wife
[Applause]
oh
foreign
[Music]
yeah she put it down slowly
it's the same story it's it's married
couple husband goes hat and cheats and
the one this is presented as a tragedy
as heartbreak as obviously an act of
Injustice and that's the beautiful
uplifting you say I'm crazy and it says
this charming British man now he's
dressing up like a sort of devilish
lesbian and he's getting titillated by
him he says tihihi at the body shop
daddy is getting weird at the body shop
and doing Unholy stuff
jiggle jiggle jiggle it's it's
so much worse it's sad it's worse and it
is a reminder that Vice will make you
worse it will make you a worse version
of yourself and virtue will make you a
better version of yourself it is an
indictment not just a Hollywood
obviously indict Hollywood this is an
indictment not just of even overt
Satanism which is very very bad it's so
funny that Sam Smith has to censor
himself from saying some expletive
probably but but he's allowed to
worship the devil on stage that's fine
you don't have to blur that out but you
can't say the naughty word
but but it it goes even further it's
it's an indictment of liberalism
and you certainly heard this with Tim
Petrus they're talking about why he is
now dancing around in devil costumes
because he says I want to do what I want
to do people say it's this is
religiously not cool but I I need to be
able to do whatever I want to do well
that's the premise of liberalism that's
the premise of Milton's Satan that's the
premise of of what happens in in the
Garden of Eden when Adam says no I just
want to do me I'm not hurting anybody
it's amazing now the liberalism that
prevails in our world says
you can do absolutely whatever you want
as long as it mostly doesn't harm other
people
as long as long as the only person that
it offends is God
else in public that then you do whatever
you want to do
as long as you're you're only offending
God that's totally fine what a bizarre
perversion of our culture happened
really really
fast head on over to dailywire.com
Knowles use code Knowles at checkout for
two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign